okay it's Friday that means it's time
for a movie retrospective kind of a wild
card today this one's a little bit I
want to say it's a little bit newer but
it's came out in 2001 which actually I
like this movie it was yeah this is one
it's like it came up on shutter we're
getting work given that shutter
subscription to work out aren't we yeah
it's quite worth it actually shudders
shudders of lip service I like you
better than Netflix act like I said
they're not paying me five dollars yeah
I like it better than Netflix yeah so I
saw this movie which is the 2001 film
frailty and I said oh I remember that
being really good mm-hmm
let's watch that one cuz I figured Tom
would probably like it I didn't remember
if you had seen it or not yeah I saw it
you know once that once I started
watching us oh yeah I remember this
movie yeah and then yeah it's like it's
weird because it's a very strange movie
um I don't know if I'd call it exactly a
pure horror movie it's kind of more like
a thriller mystery type thing um but it
has like a lot of horror elements in it
there's not a lot of gore or anything
yeah and it ends up being basically kind
of like a supernatural thriller yeah a
psychic thriller or something and yeah
really weird movie now this is I can
make a lot of connections with this
movies and other movies that would blow
your minds too I like this movie because
it is not what it seems to be on the
surface yeah and it's really kind of
like it is in a direction that a lot of
movies don't go in right it seems to be
kind of like sacrilegious and kind of
like against like the Christian religion
at first and then all of a sudden you
started thinking wait a minute is this a
Christian fundamentalist movie yeah and
I think some people are left with that
impression but I had a different
interpretation of it yeah going a bunch
of different ways once once you you you
really look into it and
is why I thought it was interesting yeah
to me it's about psychic abilities yeah
you know but yeah this was actually
interestingly enough this was the first
feature film that was directed by the
famous actor Bill Paxton
it was obviously in aliens yeah he's
dead now yeah he died early last year he
had a stroke when he was having a heart
surgery yeah died young yeah you was he
was actually quite young all right but
this was his first and actually I always
forget about this this is his first
movie that he directed but I totally
forgot that he directed the video for
fish-heads by Barnes and Barnes never
liked the early 1980s you know some
[ __ ] fish heads
I'm not everybody new fish no yeah he
directed that he directed a lot of music
videos and stuff like that but this was
actually his first movie can't 2001
actually has some big snow song fish
heads too and I always I keep forgetting
it's like that's cuz it's just so right
but yeah so this is his first movie a
lot of big stars in it actually Matthew
McConaughey is in it powers Boothe isn't
it and it's kind of like it kind of
comes at you one way and then it's got
like a cup and I'm gonna say right now
we're gonna have to spoil the twists cuz
there's more than one yeah there's kind
of two big twists in it and I'm telling
you right now we're gonna have to spoil
them otherwise we're not gonna be able
to tell ya a place where they can watch
this if you haven't seen this movie and
you're like a right turn this off and go
why I want to see this you probably
wanna cuz we are totally gonna watch the
movie first yeah so go ahead and like
shut it down because we're gonna spoil
it and really I don't think the movie is
as enjoyable once you know which
direction it's gonna go you know we
can't do we can't do the setup it's
about a boy telling the story about his
father who's getting these hearing the
voice of God and God is telling him to
go out and kill these people and the
reason why he's killing us because God
says that they're actually demons that
have been trying to come to this other
dimension
and the boy has a little brother and a
little brother he's like yes what dad
says we have to do and and he's like
telling a little brother man
dad's nuts you know you know these
people aren't demons you know they're
just innocent people and he's killing
them
and dad and his dad's laying hands on
him and he can see their sins and [ __ ]
and that's just the beginning of this
movie yes so that's the setup that's a
good time to like if you don't need
that's all I can spoil this flick yeah
this sounds like this should be a movie
that you'd like to see go ahead and
watch it now and turn it off yeah right
I think that's that's a good setup but
you think yeah yeah that's that's good
enough
I mean basically like I said it almost
starts like a serial killer police
procedural type of thing because at the
beginning you're seeing Matthew
McConaughey who is allegedly the
grown-up brother of the so called God's
hand serial killer who the FBI has been
looking for so he pulls up outside
powers booths office and powers booth is
that you know the FBI agents been
working on the case and he's basically
like oh guess what my brother is the
God's hand killer I stole an ambulance
and his body is outside an ambulance
right now cuz I told my barium in this
specific place and all this other stuff
so most of the story is told in
flashback form right um Matthew
McConaughey guys telling the feds about
how he grew up right dad did allegedly
the older brother Fenton and he's
talking about how his younger brother
Adam is the God's hand killer and he's
talked about how it started and he said
you know we had our mother died and then
dad who is never given a name he's just
called dad through the whole who's
actually played by Bill Paxton who also
directed the movie that they had like a
pretty normal life and then all of a
sudden one day dad says oh by the way
God came to me in a vision or a dream or
whatever and said that we have to be
demon slayers now and that we're gonna
know like where all the magical tools
are and [ __ ] like that like God will
tell us and he'll give us a list of like
all these evil that are demons that we
have to go kill them and like I said
apparently the older brother is like nah
yes
do that but then the little kid is just
like we mean we're like superheroes and
then yeah that's like yeah and he's like
all right I'm on board
yeah what's funny is like the older
brothers like manners cameras in there
he goes don't worry God will protect us
and it was like man we're gonna kill
this guy out in public don't worry no
one will see ya
God said it's okay you know yeah we're
just gonna end it and it's just
ridiculous yeah like a hardware store
yeah like in the middle of the day yeah
no don't worry about it don't worry
about it God says thank God said he's
got it covered they got away with it
yeah so the creepy thing so you think
that it's going that way which I which
again it's really creepy enough because
you think okay well the dad's lost his
marbles obviously the older kid is the
only one that sees reason out of this
whole thing and it's really scary and
it's like this kind of child abuse kind
of thing yeah because it's like he's
axing people to death in front of these
two little kids
yeah choking some all right it's not a
person yeah any put hands on goes did
you see that and I think the little boys
the little boy said yeah I can see says
you saw what he did yeah I saw it but
the older ones nobody's like oh man
you're tripping yeah so there's like
this horrible conflict because I mean
the kids they're not old like the older
kid Fenton I think he's supposed to be
10 11 12 something like that and then
the younger brother Adam is supposed to
be like 9 you know and it's totally on
board yeah he's like little little kid
yeah he claims to have seen it eek also
claims to have seen angels didn't he
yeah and it heard what God said I own a
couple of times yeah yeah but he said
well bill Paxton's character dad he
actually sees the angel at one point
like where he's a mechanic and he's like
working on a car and then all of a
sudden he sees that's pretty much the
only time you get to see like a kind of
supernaturally looking visions like this
big angel comes down and he looks all
pissed off and then suddenly he's like
oh that's that's the list I got to start
writing all these people's names down
yeah and so he first hit list have a
phone books to what he was going through
the phone book um well he was going
through the phone book to find out where
they live where they lived okay but the
angel addresses I guess but the angel
gave me the name Joe gave him the
okay yeah because as soon as he came out
from under the far after seeing the
angel he pulled out his little pads
right and all the names down yeah um but
then so like I said yeah he was looking
at the phonebook so I guess he was
looking for the address cuz like so you
think that it's going along this
particular route that it's like okay
here's these two little kids their dad
just suddenly flipped out and decided
that God told him that he should kill
all these people and all this other [ __ ]
but then now which I can't remember it's
like we just watched it a couple nights
ago blows it now the twist that comes
first so like I said this whole thing is
being told pretty much in flies like two
long flashbacks and like fruits between
the first twist he tells the little
brother the boy the older brother told
the little brother he was gonna go to
the police or something rat on dad which
he did which he did and but then dad
said ah you know he talked his way out
of it with the police and dad put the
kid in the basement yeah that's right
old chilies have a revelation till God
would show him but he never happened he
kept down there for a long time - yeah
they didn't say I think it was like a
week maybe it's like he didn't starve to
death but close you don't think he was
even giving him water was he well the
little brother was getting water yeah
well he wasn't sneaking the dad said he
could okay yeah I think he never has the
vision and the dad said I'm not gonna
believe what the angel told me remember
that yeah yeah that kind of stuff yes
kind of gave him a second chance
even though he never had the vision well
they were on a mission to kill this
biker who had evidently done something
bad he was touching him you know and the
you know they'd captured him and brought
him back to the little slaughterhouse
that they would kill him yeah where they
would kill him and he was laying hands
on him and seeing what he'd done what he
had done he goes he didn't know anybody
saw that you know did you you know and
the the little brother he was all in on
it he was like yeah yeah I see it that
kind of deal and the that he gave the
axe to the older son the one who didn't
have the vision and he told him to kill
the guy yeah he said like because then
the older kid lied to get out of yeah
basement yeah God talk to me that's
right and the dad is just like okay yeah
that's right no the next demon so the
older son was getting ready to [ __ ] back
like that to cut the dudes head off and
instead he swung the axe around and hit
his dad right in a chest with killed his
dad right in front a little brother now
that the first twist yeah and here's
what I found interesting about that
whole segment of the plot was that
here's the thing God apparently
allegedly tells dad hey here's a list of
people who are for real demons you need
to go and chop them up with an axe and
bury them in the garden and you know
it'll be fine I'll fix it so you don't
get caught but then apparently the angel
tells him that Fenton the older kid is
also a demon yeah he's also a demon yeah
but the dad doesn't want to believe that
yeah even though for real he's like oh
kill all these people
gotcha right but then the angel says I
don't remember if it actually expressly
said that he was a demon I think they
said he was maybe his name wasn't
written in the book or some something
like that I thought it was implied that
Fenton was a demon okay well because he
I think the reason that dad didn't say
that wrong because he didn't want to
make the kid feel bad cause he was still
kind of giving him a chance cuz it was
his son well make a long story short the
kid that's the grown kid that is now
telling the feds the story of what
happened to his dad and everything he's
telling this federal agent this over
near where he supposedly buried all
these papers right and turns out that
the little that the grown son is not the
older son he's actually the younger son
that believed that the believer yeah and
he killed his he killed his brother yes
it had him buried down to there and the
reason why he's telling him that is
because this that this grown younger
little brother knows the evil that the
federal agent did he grabbed him like
that and you get to see that the federal
agent murdered his mom yeah because it
should be nobody else knew it up to this
point the audience has not been privy to
these visions right all you see
when Dad touches the person or when Adam
touches the person or whatever all you
see is them like going oh like acting
like they're shocked or like yeah that's
refined somehow when you don't see
anything until the end and when he
touches the federal agent the federal
agent somehow knows that he saw it yeah
and he came out and told you he said you
killed your mom bo-buddies how did you
know that so he confirmed he confirms to
you to the audience that the decision is
true right so he kills that guy and it's
revealed later on that the little the
grown kid you know what his real job is
is he's a sheriff he's a local sheriff
and he's got a wife and a kid and he's
doing God's work well hunting down ways
a cop by day by night he's hunting these
evil people that had escaped justice so
you're left wondering well damn is this
a Christian fundamentalist kind of an
apocalyptic movie what was that but the
more I thought about it actually it's a
movie a lot like unbreakable anyway this
character is a lot like the character
that Bruce Willis was he could kind of
detect you see a lot of times in a lot
of movies and you know I've had a
near-death experience I've seen I've had
out-of-body experiences I've had one
poltergeist incident that Jenny wrote a
book about a lot of times human psychic
abilities are kind of perceived through
a through a prism of religion so had
this story been taking place somewhere
in another country maybe it would have
been Islam you know what I mean or been
the story would have been told through a
prism of maybe Buddhism or if this story
were taking place a long time ago in a
galaxy far far away maybe these would
have been Jedi hunting hunting down Sith
you know so I don't really see it as a
religious movie per se I thought more of
a psychic movie but because these guys
were southerners you know it had a
veneer Southern Baptist
yes a collectivist Texas right yeah and
tamiya you know coming from Mississippi
I thought that [ __ ] was cool as [ __ ] I
liked it the interesting thing about
this movie I'm like I said you could be
forgiven for the big twist at the end
because not only it should be noted not
only did Matthew McConaughey actually
apparently see this FBI agent killing
his mother like with his psychic
abilities or god or gods anyway right
yeah and apparently that was true
because the you know Wesley Doyle who
powers Boothe played the FBI agent he
said how did you know that so obviously
that's a true thing and it should be
noted afterward that they knew like the
FBI knew that Wesley Doyle was dead they
found his ID and it had blood all over
and everything I don't think they ever
found where he was buried or anything
but when um when Matthew McConaughey was
leaving the FBI I think cuz they're like
oh well we got him on camera and he was
in here for like hours and hours and
guess what when they watched the tape
back the tape was all [ __ ] up yeah
yeah yeah yes like that and then when
the FBI like goes back to the town and
it turns out that Matthew McConaughey is
actually the town sheriff
yeah and he walks out and you're like oh
my god he's the sheriff and the FBI
agent doesn't recognize him even though
he looked at him for hours and hours so
they were being protect so they were
being predicted sooo photographed and
they they're there they're there their
identities are being clouded people's
memories are being clouded yeah so you
know you could interpret it as hey is
God protecting them or is it the force
protecting on it said to go axe or is it
mental domination you know what I mean
because you know some people that have
you know claim to have exhibit some
psychic abilities they seem to kind of
they're able to do them when they kind
of have I guess you could say a selfless
quality to them where they can say oh
it's not me doing it it's God doing it
it's not me doing it it's the demon
doing it or it's the poltergeist doing
it you know what I mean in this so in
this particular case explanation is that
it's God you know right if these weren't
so
baptists maybe sit there was some kind
of a new-age cult that was doing this
they would say what was the universe you
know the universe is doing it or the
force is working through us it's like
that what we were talking about it oh
that's cool flick
when we were talking about it earlier I
thought to myself you know this could be
even if there was no I mean obviously
there's a supernatural element to it
which you find out at the end because
like I said the first three quarters of
the movie you just think this guy's a
nut job and you know he's just hacking
up these innocent people but then you
find out that these people were actually
bad people are bad things in the past
like they had murder people murder
children they were child ones yes or
whatever I think you were murder in
those kills you know this must yeah so
it's almost kind of like I always felt
like it was they were kind of going for
maybe it was like Dexter okay yeah but
supernet like if Dexter didn't have to
do all the research like if he just knew
cuz yes you could also say like a
superhero oh yeah I mean you know the
Jedi cut Sith in half and do you
lightsaber fights and [ __ ] like like I
said it's a very strange movie but yeah
could be because it has that veneer like
you said it had issues yeah yeah and in
a way that veneer kind of exposes your
own prejudiced against Christianity that
oh they're just whack us and you're
tough no he's actually doing this [ __ ]
yeah I know this shit's really happening
you know I mean so that kind of adds to
the weirdness of this movie well that's
what's so weird about it it's like when
you think about like I said when you
watch it like and I'm not saying
anything like I really like this movie I
thought it was really well directed
really well acted it's it's actually
quite creepy yes way disturbing yeah and
I think that's one of the reasons why
it's disturbing is because one it has
the courage of its conviction yes that's
a bad thing where it's like here's a guy
who was a serial he's acting people to
death and supposedly these are innocent
people but then you find out that no no
they're not innocent people and what he
was right like he was having visions
that these were bad people and he was
killing them and then he was being
protected by God or whatever force rise
so it actually did have the courage to
go yeah and what's funny is that others
other other tales kind of can do the
same thing and then you accept them like
oh there's no problem like what if what
if this was like the shadow no the other
super the shadow doing things kind of
like that
chanting evil being able to know what
the evil that men do and going after
them you know now he didn't chop their
heads off in a basement he ended up
shooting number arrested him if he had
to depend but it's that same situation
what if the story would probably be
easier for an American audience or more
palatable or easier to accept if these
were portrayed as some kind of weird you
know
Eastern wushu you know buddhist monks
that are doing this through some kind of
meditation you know me and then people
like oh yeah it's like kung fu powers
you know but if you say no these are
Southern Baptists doing it you know
that's one step away from them you know
snake handlers and you know drinking
poison you know and what if they were
doing that Dexter before like Dexter
he's an antihero I guess but you do kind
of root for him he is a very sympathetic
character yes he's a serial killer but
he kills other serial killers so you're
kind of down with that yeah but because
it doesn't have any trappings of
religion on top of it yeah it seems I
feel like it was yeah it was like easier
to swallow Ross he was just a regular
guy who happened to be a serial killer
he was just going out modern secular
Americans are so used especially of our
generation they're so used to being lied
to by televangelists and these [ __ ]
Christian cults that are around here you
know I mean we just kind of expect them
just to be hacks and to be fakes right
and nuts ya know and he kind of used
that yeah you know to the you know to
kind of subvert yeah the subversive
movie yeah oh yeah it takes it takes the
[ __ ] that takes [ __ ] you you don't
believe in and good it does play on your
prejudices it does yeah it's so
interesting and I think and I mean
honestly I don't really think that it
really didn't do much business when it
came out it was generally pretty
positively reviewed when it first came
out particularly Roger Ebert actually
really liked it and he gave it like a
really glowing review in the year since
it seems like it's a little bit
underappreciated but it does feel like
it's I mean it's come up on like a
really lot of like best horror movies of
that decade list that I've seen like
it's kind of an underrated gem type of
thing and like I said it's almost like
I've never seen another movie like that
I think the only one that I can think of
that's kind of similar was actually not
a horror movie but it was that one the
rapture that had Mimi Rogers in it yeah
I think that's when I was thinking of
her that was kind of similar was there
was because I was thinking there was one
that came out a few years before this
one yeah that reminded me of that one
too and it was like an apocalyptic yeah
that's probably think it's all [ __ ]
it turns out the apocalypse was had it
was real yeah but she like I said it's
kind of a similar theme yeah it kind of
gives me that same kind of vibe and um
also I think the only criticism a lot of
people had was though they didn't really
like the switcheroo it seemed like it
not so much you know Oh diamonds are
real but the switcheroo between Adam and
Fenton because they thought oh well it
seems a little too usual suspects type
of thing it almost seems like that but
this movie sometimes felt kind of like
what M night Shama Rama dingo that's
what I just said you know like that in
fact well not you know but it's kind of
like has a similar but better it's
better I actually like this better than
even though I like I liked unbreakable
yeah and I liked the one that the kids
could see ghosts what was the name of
that one six that's six cents that was
actually a good movie aspera is pretty
good money now I've heard that some of
his cuz he had a run of kind of
questionable ones there for a while like
the village was all right I didn't see
lady in the water cuz I just heard it
was atrocious so I didn't bother but I
heard that his newer one split was
actually pretty good in it so I actually
have to see that and we should see that
because yeah that new one glass that's
good yeah yeah yeah that's awesome
it's kind of like an unbreakable yeah
but it has the guy from split there
wasn't like this blip first I thought
unbreakable was a missed opportunity
that should have come out a series like
that should have come out before the you
know before all these Marvel serious man
big
like he should he should have kept going
with that I think that would've worked
he should have yeah yeah I feel like
like I said I feel like em night you
know we're kind of getting off time yeah
I'm just saying I kind of feel like em
night like he had one really good idea
like six cents that was like a good
movie and then it seemed like oh well
that's my shtick I have to do like a
twist and you doing that and when they
keep doing that they just get more and
more ludicrous and you just can't move
it by it
the twist in this one I mean and I'm not
talking about like I said the demons a
real twist cuz that's pretty crazy but
I'm just the twist between like the two
characters being switched it wasn't
really all that ludicrous you know the
guy just came in and he's like I'm my
brother and yeah but really it was just
you know opposite identity so you know I
didn't think it was that egregious so it
didn't bother me all that much no it was
impossible but like I said yeah the it's
just interesting because this movie is
like it's really um thought-provoking
like it will bring up a lot of and and I
think it's interesting how you said that
yeah it kind of brings up brings out
people's prejudices maybe against that
type of thing because you're so used to
Oh some here's some crazy fundamentally
yeah yeah hacking people up until God to
do it this time he did yeah that way or
he ever he person yeah and then like it
the movie kind of ends where they show
that killed the killer okay yeah come in
on surveillance tape and wherever his
face is there's a damn line of static
you can't see never like what have you
doing this
so you turns out yeah they they were
protected but it just leaves it up and
were they protected by God were they
protected by some kind of an internal
psychic force or something that he was
admitting where they're protected by
some kind of a universal force that he
was channeling like a Jedi you don't
know where were they protected by a
demon that was where they were taking to
be yeah you don't know I don't think it
was a demon well it could have been
because I would say left it ambiguous
because when he grabbed the federal
agent you actually saw the vision and
the federal agent said how did you know
about that so he confirmed that it was a
true vision yeah they were evildoers
that they were killing yeah so you know
I would think if it was a diamond they'd
be you know they'd they'd be killing
good it'd be like
[Laughter]
some kind of a universal force was
working through them they they kind of
saw it as God in a Southern Baptist way
you know was making him go out and
destroy these evil people because God
wanted it you know the kid was like why
are we doing this just don't you can't
question it there's a plan God says we
have to do it yeah and don't worry about
anything we can't get caught yeah he's
protecting us that's what I mean yeah
it's kind of who are you to question
some [ __ ] like that they kidding I get
you on video I'd be like okay all right
like this is how rose like I said it's a
pretty disturbing movie and it's like
kind of it's pretty thought-provoking
and like I said I haven't really seen
another one like this um and like I said
it's interesting how I mean this was
Bill Paxson's big debut
and it has the like I said it has the
courage of its conviction it's yeah
they're like you know I guess [ __ ] you
it takes the story and it takes it to
its logical conclusion and it's just
like you know and if you don't like it
it's just like it's tore that what if
yeah what if that [ __ ] was true
ya know that's exactly what was it
exactly and so what if X was it's like
what if every serial killer that said Oh
God told me to kill these what if that
was actually what if that was actually
hello oh they're important there would
have been a difference you know why
because these guys couldn't be caught on
film there and no evidence is being left
behind yeah you couldn't even look at
him and recognize him if you were an
investigator yeah so other serial
killers didn't have that advantage which
meant that they were not protected by
this force of this god I kind of wonder
that like so this is just one dinky
little town in Texas where this one guy
doing this he you got a big list of
demons man there's well there must be
there must be more of them that's what I
was just gonna say so that implies the
gods pick in like one person isin arias
little town and he's like hey here's how
this two people then here's another
thing it was his dad not his older
brother but then the younger brother
yeah but that goes along with the Luke
Skywalker thing of will it runs in my
family
yeah and that's a weird [ __ ] I kind of
like your idea about how they have the
executive powers like it doesn't have to
anything to do with things like oh it's
like the force yeah they just
interpreted that they interpreted as
their interpret it through their own
cultural filter that's what I thought
when I saw that's actually they yeah
that's like kind of a cool reading
because that would be the logical way
like if this is going on around the
earth right it's not going to be
Baptists in in in in in Thailand yeah
it's gonna be Buddhists in Thailand
doing it you know
yeah and maybe in another place you know
in China you know where there's it's all
a theists they got guys doing it but
that's not religion it's atheists that
are doing it right and they're doing
their thinking they may have a different
interpretation of this yeah it might be
you know well I'm being driven this to
some kind of a quantum force that's
working through me and it's something
extra dimensional you know they might
have a totally different interpretation
of what's happening to them you know
interesting and like I said you know I
know if you haven't seen it well sorry
we just spoil [ __ ] poopy but we did
warn you yeah be warned Warner but yeah
it's on it might be on some other
services I'm sure it probably is but
it's on shudder at the moment and it's
really kind of a not me guys if you're
not paying that five bucks a month that
shutter service you're kind of missing
out five bucks a [ __ ] month and well
they're not paying us they're not people
I just looked like I said it five
dollars would be too much if they didn't
have anything worth watching everything
here is pretty good they have a lot of
[ __ ] there with well like they have oh
there's a [ __ ] ton of classics and stuff
like that and I was like like I said I
was scrolling through and I came across
this when I said they got it Xbox apps
we watch it through my xbox there's an
Xbox app full sometimes I watch it on my
lap right yeah so you can just watch
anywhere yeah yeah so it's on shutter
and check it out frailty from 2001 and
like I said it's a bill Paxson's
directorial debut at least for a feature
film because he passed away early last
year so you should probably check it out
and that will do it for our latest movie
retrospective remember if you liked the
show like share subscribe it really
helps us out a lot if you'd like to
financially support show you can go to
our patreon page at patreon.com slash no
student clock podcast or you can go to
our blog which is 13 o'clock podcast up
wordpress stop
and there's a link in the sidebar to a
PayPal account if you'd like to give a
one-time donation also remember that our
movie reviews come out every Friday our
regular episodes come out every Tuesday
and our 13 o'clock matinee show which is
the three new movies that we watched in
the theater every week come out every
Sunday so check those out as well we
will see you next time
bye